Dodd's is duly elected member of
parliament for the said constituency the
announcement was made in an Ocoee hall
in mid wales but this results will be
heard very clearly in London the Liberal
Democrats have taken this seat of Brecon
and ravisher from the ruling
Conservative Party it whittles Boris
Johnson's parliamentary majority down to
just one MP the new leaders pre vote
visits of Wales wasn't enough to prevent
the chances of a government collapse
going up barely nine days since he took
over as Prime Minister this is why this
by-election was so significant because
we're looking at a general election very
shortly and it really showed some of the
key factors that are going to be at
playing up in that election a resurgent
remain of vote under the Liberal
Democrats and also brexit party to
contend with the Boris Johnson the
Liberal Democrats newest MP was clear
about what she thinks this result means
but some voters do want to know deal
brexit and although Nigel Farage's
brexit party didn't perform quite as
well as they might have hoped with 10%
of the vote they still arguably cost the
Conservative MP his seat by splitting
the Pro brexit vote although local
issues are often important for
by-election results this one can also be
seen as another example of how brexit is
rewriting the balance of Britain's
political system with support for
smaller parties like the Lib Dems and
the brexit party on the rise at the
expense of the big - labour and the
Conservatives when Parliament returns
from recess at the beginning of
September it will have less than two
months till brixi Day and Boris Johnson
the man who said he will deliver it come
what may is clinging on to power by his
fingertips
Rory challenge how to zerah London